et si des yvelines devenait le pôle
d'innovation de renault avec le plan
d'économies du groupe présenté par la
direction le programme prévoit deux
milliards d'économies notamment une
réduction de 800 millions d'euros des
coûts sur l'ingénierie
l'objectif est de réduire la diversité
des véhicules et de concentrer le
développement des technologies à haute
valeur ajoutée sur les sites d'île de
france notamment au technocentre de
guyancourt notre technocentre qui est
célèbre située à guyancourt restera une
forteresse technologiques françaises
toutes les études technologie
d'électrification seront bien entendu
centraliser la technologie des services
de transport intelligents touski
connectivité tout ce qui reposera sur 4
g 5 g tous ces sujets fondamentaux dans
laquelle d'ailleurs renault sera désigné
comme un des grands leaders dans
l'alliance seront évidemment centralisée
au technocentre
malgré cette concentration près de 4600
postes sont concernés par des mesures de
reconversion de départs volontaires en
france au technocentre les premières
hypothèses évoquent 1500 personnes
concernées la restructuration de
l'activité ingénierie passe aussi par la
réduction du nombre de sous-traitants
c'est beaucoup de centres de d'algérie
partenaires on va dire qui risque d'être
obligé de supprimer des emplois et pour
renault technocentre c'est également un
départ de certaines activités que nous
faisons sur le set et qui donc il y aura
des suppressions de postes le voir
piloter croissance des effectifs au
regard de l'activité puisque aujourd'hui
faut se le dire
le nageur et renault agents étaient en
cours hier sous tension ces dernières
années donc là il va faire piloter cette
décroissance d'activité
une façon intelligente et que tout le
monde se retrouve - soit pas
déstabiliser par encore une
réorganisation qui serait pas forcément
judicieuses des discussions sont déjà
engagées entre la direction et les
partenaires sociaux
autre conséquence de ce plan d'économies
le programme le tcr de rénovation du
technocentre pourrait être revu et re
est étudié pour réduire les coûts